this election were overturned  by mere allegations from the losing side  our democracy would enter a death spiral  we'd never see the whole nation except  an election again  every four years would be a scramble for  power  at any cost  the electoral college  which most of us on this side have been  defending for years  would cease to exist  leaving many of our states  with no real say at all in choosing a  president  the effects would go even beyond the  elections themselves  self-government my colleagues requires a  shared commitment  to the truth and a shared respect  for the ground rules of our system  we cannot keep drifting apart  into two separate tribes with a separate  set of facts  and separate realities  with nothing in common except our  hostility towards each other and  mistrust for the few national  institutions  that we all still share  every time